let's continue taking calls we are going
next to our caller from the 705 area
code caller in 705
what's your name and what's your
question today I David ah my name is
Lyle I'm just calling from Sudbury
Ontario great well I'm Haneda I'm just
sort of gotten but yeah just want to
talk about just a well obviously both
Donald chunks but just his thoughts on
Twitter um it's unreal
pretty much just how this guy is 70 plus
years old and he's basically changed the
whole aspect of like is when we were
younger we're looking at like MySpace we
have picked so we have all these social
media things we had when we were younger
and we're going out now we're going to
grow up we're going to get over that now
this guy 70 years old 70 plus I don't
even know how old is 71 yeah and he's
got his surrogate look yeah there you go
he's got a sitter gets the call you kill
hand con me coming on all the time just
toting all this 100 million followers
over Facebook over social media
platforms it's like I just find it so
pathetic that that this is their talking
point
unbelievable and just I just wanted to
get your idea on um well that's what I
did huh just believe a couple of years
ago Twitter had done a thing where they
went through all of the fake accounts
and eliminated so it really kind of
exposed a certain for certain popular
like Kim Kardashian for example lost 20
million followers or something like that
I was wondering if they could
potentially do something like that
expose this guy and shut up to some
language there shut up killing any
economy with these talking points yeah
so that's been done Twitter audit looked
at if you look at Trump's fault
Trump's account on Twitter audit it
claims that roughly half of his
followers are fake now I don't know how
accurate that is like it says seven
percent
my followers are fake and and what so I
think that some fraction of it is
accounts that like you said it's not
that they're fake but it's accounts that
have been closed because some some part
of that happened but I think I think
your first point is the most interesting
one which is it's sort of weird for a 71
year old to be so focused on tweeting at
3:00 a.m. whether or not their president
of the United States Pat it's even
weirder when the person obsessed when
when the 71 year old obsessed with
tweeting at 3:00 a.m. happens to be
President of the United States that's
really odd especially when it's been
proven time and time again was bad for
him and that he's undermining his own
lawyers and his own policy proposal yeah
I mean the fact that they're staging
interventions or try to get him to stop
using Twitter and those aren't working
yeah it's really concerning all right
well thanks very much we've got to run I
appreciate the call appreciate the topic
very very interesting and hope to hear
from you again